what did you guys do for Christmas I
went to the mountains in Georgia and I
got sick for five days it was so fun
everyone had fun playing board games I
was in bed were you sick you sick now oh
you weren't safe during the break no no
no I'm screaming really hard for
Christmas I had to prepare this entire
house for it's an obsession yeah I saw
your guys you you love it that you look
like a pure joy I'm doctor to pure joy I
mean I love you yeah yeah I mean I I but
I don't do [ __ ] for it I say I show up
well there's one thing that he does and
explain what you do for the Bob oh so
what I do is this I ask how many people
are coming over so we had what 19 yeah
20 and I said okay so I buy 20 gifts and
I wrapped them some of the gifts are
great some of them are the worst gifts
you could get like on both ends of the
spectrum right so in my Bob Nan's I had
I wrapped a Playstation 4 Jesus I should
have stayed to know an iPad [ __ ] right
and then some of the boxes is a rock the
other one was hard for nothing so that's
a gift card they turn on to zero yeah
then I have some gift cards that are
worth stuff like $150 Urban Outfitters
but the rules are if you approach
bobbies about Nan's abox yeah where he
lays out the gifts in front of you you
can't shake you can't touch so if your
finger lands on it that's the that's the
game kind it's a game yeah right so some
people were like so stoked like Steve's
girlfriend got the PlayStation she
couldn't believe it Julianna got the
iPad Julianna whoa and then some people
got rocks and there was a Donald Trump
can opener that I and John Donald Trump
Mints and I got a Hawaii an immense that
we couldn't find a goddamn it we
couldn't find it but then we found it
later you know I mean but I wish that
was a part of it as well but his mom
came down for Christmas I was the first
in how long has ever been
okay so my mom my mom my mom has never
had a Christmas like that you know um
during Christmases in the LA I mean the
last 10 years of her life
she's still alive but um my dad had a
stroke so he was paralyzed and she just
became a nurse for ten years digging
[ __ ] out of his ass no gifts no tree no
marry I mean we call her a Merry
Christmas but nothing so she comes to
this house and she sees all these new
people and she sees the trees and the
gifts and the fun and games and the food
and the laughter and um she really
really enjoyed herself
Calathes mom and my mom met for the
first time was the first time yeah and
they're scary together they really hit
it off I think they're gonna rub vaginas
inviting each other like okay come see
me in Arizona okay and they were like
making plans and stuff like that's
[ __ ] they took photos with face to
face touching faces you it's cute as
[ __ ] that's cute yeah and it was
probably the best Christmas I've ever
had it's awesome because it's not
because I'm sober again all that stuff
that has a lot to do with it but I you
know I was the first time truly looking
forward to and open to this idea cuz
kalila works so hard on it three trees
we have in the house do we have to
retreat yes three trees doc I didn't get
there's a thing like we I we didn't get
back into town until the 21st of
December so between the 20 and we
celebrate on the 24th so I had three
days to prepare the whole house and I
think I did a bang-up job good she not
she not only she did a bang-up job it
was the right people came over and you
know hopefully next year and because you
know when I first was sober back in the
day
I would have a birthday party and would
bring a people to and because I drifted
away from members of Alcoholics
Anonymous for so long that I didn't
invite you know people to anything
because I just wasn't involved but I'm
so involved right now that I think
that's gonna be incorporated into it as
well you know I'm trying to be more I
know I go to the Comedy Store and I talk
to doorman I used to what's up fatty
you're like Dylan he's a fat gay guy